i'm gonna go right right into this
right you're you're known for for
believing in ufos
very very many experiences with aliens
and ufos
and now it's on cnn they're saying
ufos are real like do you feel like
i've told you so for so long i've been
saying so and now you finally believe me
i uh i never i never had experience with
elliot i
when i was young i did what uh
psychologists call sleep paralysis
so it's a phenomenon that happened that
when it happened to a lot of people
and that's what they tell me that when
you sleep
you you paralyze and your brain produce
certain chemicals that can make you a
loosening
i don't remember my experience what
happened i remember that i had
experience but i didn't remember
what really happened but i remember that
still now today i have a fear
of it even in the dark like i'm a grown
man i'm 40 years old and sometimes
some some remnants of it it's in my head
that i'm afraid but i don't know why i'm
afraid when i wake up in the middle of
the night but
it could be it's described as sleep
paralysis
so and for ufo it doesn't mean you have
flu it's an alien we don't know
like i i it's an unidentified flying
object and i think they changed their
name now for uap
unindentify aerial phenomenon so
we don't know i mean i i personally
believe yes they
i think if we think we're the only one
in the universe i think
i think not that is wrong but we don't
have the poop but i think the universe
is so big there's probably life
i don't know if they came here but i you
know it wouldn't
it would not surprise me if they did all
right
yeah i mean i mean i haven't even like
been
particularly uh you know up in arms
about it but it seems pretty
interesting that like it's mainstream
media the pentagon is announcing ufos
are real
the funny thing too is people are just
like oh yeah okay like nobody there's no
nobody's freaking out really
like no one's they're just kind of like
soft lobbing us all this
that that's what surprised me the most
it's it's crazy
they talk about cove this should be the
front page of
every newspaper i mean it's imagine if
we
i mean maybe it's chinese maybe you know
it's russia
i don't know but imagine if we because
they know now that it's
intelligently control whatever it is you
know they
the pilot talk about it and
intentionally
jump their radars you know so that's
mean it's it's intelligently controlled
it's not a phenomenal like a random
phenomenon
from nature yeah that's mean it's really
something like
legit but we don't know what it is it is
you know
it's it's crazy but imagine if we put
our end into this and we can back an
engineer
the technology the the now we we
we spend like like a lot of uh time and
then effort on fossil
fossil fuel and and all that all the
energy
that they had it could change a planet i
think that's that's the
the most rewarding thing about that that
stuff
it could change the world yeah
absolutely
yeah i mean it's it's pretty fascinating
i mean even with the uh
the the colonel favor that was on
everybody's podcast talking about the
little pack
i mean if if they thought that china had
this type of technology like we'd be on
like
you know category five alert but like
because they
don't know what it is like i have no big
deal yeah you know it's pretty it's
pretty crazy
and what about like sorry go ahead
i think the problem is there's a lot of
conspiracy theory
uh about it so this subject has been
ridiculed
for so many times you know it's uh
it's when you want to hide something and
play the best ways to hide it in
in plain sight so to speak you know you
ridicule the subject so everybody is
afraid to talk about it because they
will be ridiculed
right so i think i don't and i don't
know if somebody
knows like but i don't think i mean
i don't think the president of the
united states because it comes and
goes every four years you know so i
don't know if a guy like this would know
every secret
i would tend to say more someone from
the kgb or the cia or something like
that maybe someone knows
what it is but yeah i don't know man
it's it's it
it's crazy yeah it's an exciting time to
be alive it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
yeah yeah
dude